how significant is this ruling well it
is significant in terms of freedom of
speech and how much a person's belief
system
even if it is offensive to some is
protected by
the law maya falstata holds what she
calls gender critical views that means
she believes
while a person can present as a
particular gender or identify with a
particular gender
sex is unchangeable of course a lot of
people find that offensive including
many trans people but mai was tweeting
about this back
in 2018 when the government was
considering changing the way
in which transgender people can
officially change their gender
so you would simply have to state which
gender you identify with
rather than having to prevent to show a
medical
diagnosis of gender dysphoria now maya
wasn't happy with that she started
tweeting about it and these tweets got
the attention of her
employer and she says she was then let
go that her contract wasn't renewed as a
result
of this so she then goes to an
employment tribunal
they ruled that her views weren't
protected from discrimination her team
had made the case that in the same way
that you can't discriminate against
someone because of their race or
religion
maya shouldn't have been discriminated
against because of what they described
as
her philosophical beliefs she then
appealed that decision and a judge
today has sided with her and this is
what maya had to say in response
so so the judgment found that my belief
which is that sex is real immutable and
important which is
just the basic belief about sex that
most people hold
is worthy of respect in the democratic
society
it overturned the previous judgment and
it said that this
this belief should be protected so
people people who hold this belief
shouldn't be discriminated against at
work
or as users of services
and they shouldn't be harassed
obviously it is worth pointing out that
a lot of people do disagree with
maya's beliefs but she used that wording
worthy of respect in a democratic
society because that
is the wording from the original
judgment a judge has now said
that isn't the case however the judge
today was
keen to state that this judgment does
not mean that transgender people can be
harassed
or discriminated against and it also
does not mean that people who hold
maya's beliefs can misgender transgender
people i.e
use the wrong pronouns and those are
points that the lgbtq plus
charity stonewall were keen to highlight
they said
that this judgment is not a massive win
for
maya however this does set a precedent
for people who
do hold maya's beliefs effectively the
judgment saying they should not
face a backlash for expressing them
and in terms of maya's case now with the
employment tribunal her employers can
appeal this decision but if they don't
this will continue in the employment
tribunal
and maya will have to prove that she was
let go because of these beliefs